bonjour d'abord et oui dans nord on boit
beaucoup de bière c'est d'ailleurs la
région où l'on boit le plus de bière en
pense
deux fois plus que la moyenne nationale
on l'utilisé même la bière en cuisine
comme on va le voir dans quelques
minutes avec notre ami pierrot qui est
toujours là ça va pire ont très bien il
aime la bière qui ira aussi aux produits
en demandait et tout à l'heure il nous
fera le coq la bière guînes en tout cas
pour l'instant où il faudrait vous
parler un petit peu de cette pierre du
nord il faut savoir que c'est le le
département français où il ya le plus de
brasserie en france il y à 28 par
inscrits au total en france dont 18 dans
le département du nord mais sans général
des petites brasseries ce qu'on appelle
des brasseries artisanales qui font des
bières très typé des bières qui ont du
caractère et qui rend compte d'ailleurs
de plus en plus de succès actuellement
en france et birr de cartes comme on dit
souvent et c'est le renard aussi que se
trouve la plus petite brasserie de
france c'est celle de debussy à la
frontière franco belge entre
valenciennes et maubeuge c'est la
brasserie bayeux elle produit aux 300 à
400 écoles hectolitres de bière par an
vous voyez que c'est pas beaucoup mais
c'est une direction tente bien un gars
du pire pur malt à base d'orge de
printemps
uniquement de fermentation haute non
filtrés refermentée en bouteille c'est
une des particularités de cette bière de
bikini qui s'appelle la cuvée des
jonquilles la saint médard ou la cuvée
spéciale de noël c'est une bière qui est
mise en doute ailleurs bouchonné bouvier
comme l'est un peu comme les bouteilles
de champagne alors sévir artisanale et
ben ils doivent leur qualité bien sûr au
talent des brasseurs et à leur amour de
ce produit de ce produit typiquement
dida elle vient aussi leurs qualités ou
houblon et oblongs des flandres car
c'est en voie de disparition
malheureusement le houblon des flandres
mais il y en a qui se bat pour essayer
de le garder parce que ils contribuent
encore une fois je voulais dit à cette
qualité des bières du nord
alors on va aller faire un petit tour
dans cette région des flandres avec un
portage de isabelle bri
[Musique]
ah ah
le spectacle de cette cueillette typique
et ancestrale s'est fait de plus en plus
rares c'est étrange forêt ont même
failli être définitivement rayé de la
carte des flandres signé houblonniers ne
s'étaient mobilisés à temps aujourd'hui
il en resterait à peine 10 hectares
heureusement après la crise des années
90 due à la surproduction mondiale
les planteurs du nord se sont lancés
dans la recherche de nouvelles variétés
et ont su petit à petit c'est bien les
bras ça demain aujourd'hui une vingtaine
d'exploitants parviennent encore à
survivre le métier est toujours aussi
difficile
les bénéfices incertain pourtant ici le
houblon est une passion il est même les
jeunes pourtant telle aventure bourrée
bal empire au ça y est maintenant voilà
on leur donnerait la bière ah bon côté
la bière alors j'ai découpé mongkok pas
devant les caméras parce que mais pour
les dames c'est quand même le coupé les
cox quand même très assez difficile et
c'est quand même assez dur je veux dire
donc si vous avez votre petit bout chez
le marchand de volailles faut mieux les
faire couper parce qu'un gros stock de 3
kilos et demi à quatre kilos comme celui
là bon il est certain que c'est quand
même assez difficile à couper alors
regardez nous allons attaquer tout de
suite nous allons mettre un peu de
saintdo pour faire revenir notre kop
mais vous pouvez mettre du beurre du
beurre mais ici pour notre ado est bien
parce que c'est vraiment le
le saint 12 dans les flandres en cuisine
beaucoup sindou et ça change un peu de
ça donne un ton un peu plus de grâce
alors un peu plus debout bon alors voilà
nous allons faire fondre notre sainte ou
alors le coq lui il vient de il vient
d'où ce top 50 des plans d'une ferme
flamande c'est pas un réseau que c'est
pas un comme de bon bah non parce que
c'est en or les clubs soient importants
mon beau père chaque fois qu'ils
rentraient d'un combat de boxe avait
perdu il rentrait qu'une petit beurre et
évidemment nous engueuler par ma
grand-mère est souvent la grand mère
elle prenait le coq le faisait mari mais
parce qu'on peut aussi faire mariner le
tout bon avant cela ici on l'a pas fait
d'espoir brille très bien les vacances
luther mariner dans la vienne la bière
avec du thym du laurier des clous de
girofle 1 peut pas mieux comme une
viande bref pour l'instant vous le
faites colorer voyez sa couleur
président lesaint louvoyer mais ça va
très très vite
[Applaudissements]
alors ça vaut ne pas mettre des gros
morceaux il ya peu près une dizaine de
morceaux de 300 grammes environ
mais comme ça ma cuire 3 heures à 4
heures ça reste quand même très fort et
on se retrouve à quatre morceaux de
viande de 200 grammes avec os alors la
cuisson du top quand on est trop cuit
faut l'avouer à coke commandes il ya la
dictature à cuire des fois ça cuit 3h
défaut sa fille 3h30
mais prenez pas de risques un plus 5,8
pouces et bon écouter le bruit le chant
du coq dans la gamme alors qu'envy avec
laure et les premiers morceaux sortir un
petit peu aux points 2
pourquoi on fait coloré bain pour que la
chaise la chair se raidissent un petit
peu quand même pour qu'après ça sous ce
terme elle pas trop vite donc la chair
elle se saisit un petit peu et c'est
quand même mieux pour la cuisson et
après le cob accuse régulièrement
voilà vous rajouter vos morceaux
évidemment envoyé que la coque de trop
de kilos et demi quand même d'un place
dans la coupe
un don il faut déjà une belle cocotte
[Musique]
voilà pendant que sako là nous allons
rajouter la moitié des lardons
vous verrez pourquoi pas ce qu'on va en
garder un petit peu pour la garniture
hommage aux femmes watch et les lardons
c'est à dire qu pas beaucoup comme
advint ça dure g de lardons un peu frais
oui pour donner un petit peu de tout ça
va bien avec le sa nouvelle offre est
trop chaud quoi voilà l avantage du coq
à la bière c'est que souvent barça va
vite apporté une très bonne odeur dans
la cuisine je vais pas dire que c'est
une machine à faire des odeurs mais
contient coq à la bière qui cuisse a
toujours une très bonne odeur dans la
cuisine
alors on va rajouter les oignons alors
vous pouvez mettre des oignons ou aussi
les échalotes
alors j'ai pris les oignons parce
qu'après tout c'est le plat ménages mais
beaucoup de gens aiment bien les
non surtout empreint de beaucoup des
flottes
voilà donc s'étaler pense que vous avez
mais on peut mettre les oignons et les
échalotes
on en est là quand même alors voyez
c'est bien coloré je vais singer sage et
ça veut dire que trois cuillères de
farine moi je le prends dans la main je
suis habitué j'aime bien les mains un
medal of honor donc nous allons sage et
nous allons mettre 2 3 cuillères de
farine à peu près et là on va laisser
cuire une ou deux minutes pour cuire la
farine dans son gaz a toujours bien ça y
est à fond et ensuite on va mettre le
geniève qui est un alcool d'une heure le
genièvre
ouais je viens à lui seul a dit m comme
brûler la voilà on voyait alors
évidemment on le voit pomme j'assure ça
flambe pierre mettez votre chevelure au
dessus à la flore mais c'est comme ça et
une flamme bleue mais voyez donc nous
pendant au genièvre
alors parce qu'il sent b nous allons
donc larose et pierre une bière de garde
à léonard et la fed nous voilà on va la
prendre et on va arroser ses bières en
grande bouteille un corps qu'elle vous
vous y allez dis voilà combien on en met
à écouter on en met un litre à litres
nbi bon là je crois qu'on va devoir
garder voyez la casserole on peut en
mettre
on va antoine leocour g qui peut donc
aller en tord ouvrir une bouteille ce
pays encore une bouteille la whey oui on
en a encore eu voilà c'est une grande
casserole on peut en mettre deux
bouteilles voyez sans problème voilà
alors doublé l'on ajouté à deux pas des
pays au nom non après après attendez
vous à du lourd à l'heure du laurier
ouais du thym je dire weeds lauriers
mais claude giroux qui doit avoir dans
ma cuisine
or ils m'ont mis une belle cuisine quand
même rien à faire du sel du bois ou
paris du poivre pour mettre mon moi
j'aime bien le point mais il faut quand
même bien pensé voilà voilà
et ici pour ça le teint défi ouais ça
m'étonne on met du pain d épice
simplement regarder comme ça et frites
est effritée parce qu'il va cuire et ses
délicieux parce que ça donne un petit
goût sucré ou à l'amertume de la ville a
quand même quitte à et vous verrez c'est
très très bon et ça va donner une très
très belle couleur à notre coq à la
bière bio ya à peu près 150 grammes en
bas mais elle va tout mettre ça absorbe
très très bien et c'est ce qui va lier
mon coq à la bière
on met un couvercle un four chaud
attention ces espaces info- chaud à 180
degrés ouais et alors là on va le mettre
trois heures à trois ans et demi mais
honnêtement à la rigueur vous
il faut vérifier la vérifier au bout de
trois heures qu'on va vous savez quoi
voilà vous le mettez au four garder
180-200 degré 3 aurait alors tirons
c'était un dur à cuire ou pas ce coach
là bas il ya bien trois heures et demie
qui est en train de cuire et il n'en a
fallu bon donc en gros 15h45 forte cure
ce coach là
alors voilà ça va être la finition
regarde faire sans éclat a dit donc oui
sa part que ben voilà c'est ce que j'ai
dit
notre coq a bien réduit évidemment alors
on va rajouter j'ai eu le temps pendant
mes trois heures et demie de faire
sauter les champignons et même si l'art
dont le reste de mes petits lardons de
tout à l'heure et j'ai fait des petits
oignons tu sois un peu brûlé nos
annonces pierre je les ai cuit à bras
c'est à dire j'ai mis du beurre de l'eau
du sucre et on l'a fait réduire et puis
après on regarde et on les accable femme
est caramélisée pardon bref tranquille
en ciel couleur brune
je vais donc enlevé mes morceaux de coq
dans les jeunes tiennent pas ouais ça
m'aiderait derrière voilà bien la balle
voyez comment vous voyez comme les
morceaux un son bien ils sont presque de
moitié à l'envoyer voilà c'est vraiment
du direct bah écoutez lloris et la
cuisine comme à la maison
mais le rebond a oui dans la sauce les
champignons et les oignons à brun way et
la finition
je lis avec un peu de crème fraîche
alors la crème fraîche et facultatif
vous n'êtes pas donc ça dépend si vous
avez la treille moi je trouve que ça
libyen on ne l'a pas vu voilà garder sa
voix là et maintenant on n'a plus qu'à
mettre je vais le prendre moi-même pour
pu brûler on a regardé payer la sauce
les oignons abou rich nelson cité un coq
qui était battu avouez finir comme ça
c'est quand même bien ouais on y va
pierre de l'usiné
[Musique]